[Musique]
de quel genre de ligne droite on parle
peu importe ce cas sur notre chemin et
falling parfaitement droites mais
montagne on creuse des rivières on
creuse des marécages
on creuse on creuse qu'on creuse est ce
que je veux savoir pourquoi vous faites
cette ligne
notre but est d'obtenir les cotations
boursières en seize mille secondes ce
qui est une milice seconde plus rapide
que n'importe qui d'autre
ok mais après qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est 500 millions de dollars par an
pourquoi ne manquent pas et votre s
évaporer se sert des gens comme des
actifs à liquider je peux faire de ta
vie un an fin on fera l'aller-retour en
15000 secondes vous ai déjà dit qu'on ne
pouvait plus moi je te dis que ça se
peut tu crois qu'elle construit sa
propre ligne
le chien se faire des millions de
dollars contre la ja tout ce que tu as
eue si quelqu'un a filtré notre champion
sato
je savais ce qu'il allait ski arrêté et
pourquoi est ce qu elle pâtit des tours
cellule a maintenant qu'il a pris il
essaie simplement de le baiser tu vois
quelques roulés attends je dois rentrer
à mon métier me that main mais je vous
rappelle dans deux ou trois heures
pourriez vous envoyer la soumission mon
bureau que j'aimerais que ce soit réglé
d'ici la fin de la journée
faut voir ça comme david marchant sur le
parquet de la bourse avec le plus gros
slingshot qui existe tera 100 colis at
qui s'écroule à genoux et on est david
ouais ouais on est david joël joël j'ai
trouvé un nouveau truc quand je suis pas
bien sûr que ce que je vois est réel et
ça m'aide à voir la différence c'est une
façon originale de combattre la
schizophrénie hier soir j'ai joué chez
qui je
je fais du baby-sitting s'est passé une
chose étrange personne
j'ai senti comme une présence
[Musique]
ce que les schizophrènes ont tous les
mêmes visions il est temps de parler
maintenant
si les primes en quelques vous soyez
capable par vous même d'identifier ce
qui est réel ou non besoin de trop près
pour l'exorciser niveau du temps tout se
passe dans votre tête vous devez arrêter
tout ça
écoutez moi bien mon garçon le dément
peut transformer la foule immense
sagesse et transformer ce lieu en folie
je m'appelle coma brut
j'ai étudié la théologie je suis
exorciste de profession un exorciste
moi l'église me commande de combattre le
mal partout où ils se trouvent
je peux savoir ce que vous voulez j'ai
besoin de votre aide
n'êtes-vous pas curieux de savoir ce qui
va se passer
cette nuit dans le village de duke anne
k et tous ses environs les femmes seules
relèveront de la promulgation
une disposition spéciale jusqu'ici mes
visions se sont toujours avérées exactes
c'est pour votre vie que je m'inquiète
les esprits malins se déchaînent les
jours de fête ils ne connaissent plus de
limites
ça risque d'être dangereux
c'est une sorcière très puissante et me
si jamais elle invoque il viendra
à
profiter rien donné tu sais si j'ai
donné du sort vous tous
à trois semaines du 30
à victor carrasco n'a pas vu le panneau
on a six
je te revoir demain tous les jours
je fais moi le
je suis content c'est vrai que tamedia
chez toi pour tuer tes parents s'étaient
pas vraiment pour la tuer je priais
sauvé
sa mission
[Musique]
je prends forget
on intérêt qui cire
avec sa chance
[Musique]
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] deux oreilles
les terrains canton car les marchés
il était là
de terre
[Musique]
quelqu'un peut-il me donner un exemple
du mythe au d'histoire qu'il fait par
lucas qu'est ce qui se passe on a trouvé
un morceau de corps humains dans la
forêt commença en morceaux l'autre
moitié a été retrouvé dans la mine
ça doit être un animal qui ai fait ça
non
[Musique]
je connais aucun animal qui force à ces
dessins ont été faits par l'âme les
élèves c'est ça qu'ils étaient dans la
mine c'est un esprit diabolique
désolé mais c'est un mythe
pour vous il peut être
[Musique]
il va venir me chercher ce dont il a
besoin
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
il est là
[Musique]
les chats sont dotés de multiples
qualités et surtout d'un don
extraordinaire
il voit ce que vous ne voyez pas
il voit même ce que vous auriez du mal à
imaginer
[Musique]
ces voies les elfes de maison
soyez les pierres n'est inventé en
commente appétit jolie poupée vous
ressentez un grand bonheur vous êtes
chez vous tout est paisible et rassurant
à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est ici que
vous voulez vivre
vous êtes heureuse apaisée votre vie va
se transformer en un conte de fées
[Musique]
on regarde les lustres et rouge
pourquoi tu ne veux pas de nous ici
c'est notre maison maintenant
elle de maison on était amis j'ai ma
famille lécher mon appartement
c'est moi le patron vous fêtez votre
départ alors tu en a eu assez avoir une
famille c'est la chose la plus
importante au monde et tout était prêt à
tout perdre
[Musique]
c'était quoi ça tu n'as pas encore
compris c'est sur mon territoire
tant que tu es en vie je suis très
heureuse que vous ayez accepté de me
débarrasser de lui je serai ton pire
cauchemar les élèves sont des êtres
gentil nous protégeons la maison
on s'est installé chez lui si tu
continues tu sais on fait du mal à ta
mère pour être heureux un elfe de maison
a besoin d'une famille aimante tu élèves
de la maison réveille toi et sept au
boulot il est temps de leur montrer de
quoi tu es capable
je dois tout faire dans cette maison
j'ai lu l'article que vous avez publié
il est d'une exceptionnelle valeur
scientifique
mon intuition me dit qu'il existe un
autre élément
vous croyez avoir découvert un nouvel
élément la science est en train de
changer
il se peut qu'il a dirigé aujourd'hui
sont les mêmes que ceux qui étaient
convaincus que la terre était plate
veulent y ait quitté mon laboratoire si
la science ne suffit pas alors c'est que
vous l'avez très mal comprise je vais
prouver qu'ils ont tort
surtout ce que les atomes était fini et
stable ce n'est pas le cas pour certains
d'entre eux j'ai appelé cela la
radioactivité
notre découverte pourrait soigner le
cancer c'est extraordinaire tu vas
changer le monde
notre travail est en lice pour le nobel
la nomination le fait ac de mon nom tu
as volé mon génie comment aussi
attribuer leurs ovations serait plus
important que tout ce qui m'intéressait
c'était la science et il y en a qui
disent que mon radium les rend malades
on peut se demander si l'humanité a
avantage à connaître les secrets de la
nature
j'ai passé ma vie entière à essayer de
comprendre la possible si mon combat et
je le remporterait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce même tweaks qui passe à
bordeaux
emmanuel croquis colombie
et
oui je sais me battre
l'eau
et d'un fidjien ajouté
cauchemar ait une convention en
championnat pas un miroir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]